Só. Você sabia que o seu cachorro pode
estar te protegendo de asma e alergias?
Pois é, parece brincadeira, mas não é.
Pesquisadores descobriram uma coisa
fascinante estudando os Amis. Essas
comunidades que vivem com animais desde
sempre têm 50% menos chance de
desenvolver asma e alergias. E sabe por
quê? Porque o contato com os bichinhos
desde cedo treina o nosso sistema
imunológico. É como se fosse uma
academia pro sistema de defesa do corpo.
Funciona assim. Quando a gente convive
com pets, principalmente na infância,
nosso organismo aprende a reconhecer
diferentes micróbios. Isso calibra
células T reguladora, que são tipos
maestros do sistema imunológico. E como
resultado temos menos reações alérgicas,
menos eczema, menos problemas
respiratórios. Até quem tem só um
cachorro em casa já reduz o risco em uns
14%. Então, da próxima vez que seu filho
pedir um bichinho, lembra dessa
conversa? pode ser o melhor remédio
preventivo que você vai dar para ele.